hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and we are back with some more
cursey glory in the world of jiu-jitsu
kaisen to examine the intriguing topic
of special grade cursed spirits and this
video at least to me feels essential
because identifying a special great
cursed spirit is not quite as easy as it
is to identify a special grade sorcerer
with sorcerers it's almost unbelievably
simplistic there's four of them they're
assigned that rank by the overarching
jutsu admin guys and each of these
sorcerers is roughly on par with each
other in terms of their ridiculous
abilities special great co-spirits on
the other hand are almost painfully
common in jiu-jutsu sen in fact i'm
certain that we've seen more special
great spirits than of any other type at
least in somewhat prominent roles so our
mission today is going to untangle this
somewhat messy grading system and
explore the vast world of special grade
spirits and it's all going to begin with
a quick round of tsukuna or sukuna a
very simple mini game the rules of which
are as follows here we have three sukuna
fingers one is a real finger that
belonged to the king of curses whilst
the other two are fraudulent fabricated
fakes now for reasons we won't go into
you will need to consume one of these
fingers to contain sukuna so it's going
to be your job to guess which is the
real finger now should you guess
incorrectly then not only will you fail
your very first youtube mission not a
good look but you will also forge a
binding vow by subscribing to the new
world review which will result in
consistent injections of cursey culture
administered directly into your youtube
feed and if you are correct then you
will of course have the privilege of
becoming sukuna's new vessel so which
finger will it be make your choice now
and we shall reveal the answer in three
two one and bam it was finger c so if
you guessed incorrectly then you know
the thing to do and please do say hi in
the comments below if you are new to our
association welcome sukuna is a very
good place to start though because
jiu-jitsu kaisen began as a far more
simplistic series within the prequel
chapters it was established there are 16
registered special great co-spirits in
the entire world which is a beautiful
number that we will not at all stick to
but let's go through who fits this
definition firstly obviously rio min
sukuna the king of curses now i don't
think it's ever explicitly stated that
sukuna is one of these 16 but you have
to make the assumption that he is he is
quite possibly the most notorious of
cursed spirits who has been known to
juju to society for over 1 000 years at
this point and is considered by many to
be the greatest threat to human
existence as we know it so i think it's
fair with that in mind to assume that
sukuna was a registered special grade
and to this day he remains almost
certainly the most powerful special
great co-spirit we've encountered
although he does have some pretty decent
competition such as sukuna's
unintentional counterpart the queen of
curses who would also fit this
registered definition potentially rika
was logged and assumedly registered by
the jutsu admin whatever's the very
moment they took note of yuta and i say
this because sugar ghetto would be the
man responsible for claiming that there
are 16 registered cursed spirits
designated as the special grades and by
the point he would have said this he
obviously knew of rika so logically she
would be one of them yes and also the
only one we know of who could really
serve as a rival to sukuna as rika all
on her lonesome managed to defeat
ghetto's big bang uzumaki thing
consisting of well over 4 000 other
cursed spirits although in theory rika
as we knew her no longer exists as her
curse was actually broken and she was
seemingly allowed to pass on into the
afterlife with that said youtube does
still appear to wield a cursed spirit
named rika to this very day and if this
is not rika then that spirit's rank is
currently unknown but if it is then
she's still very very special however
during the prequel we were treated to an
officially registered special grade
being the tamimo no my incarnate this is
a bizarre little existence because this
has a subclassification of being an
imaginary vengeful spirit meaning that
it didn't manifest directly from an
individual but rather from the pure fear
of a collective mass of people although
sadly we know very little about it
because ghetto just summons the tamamo
and then seemingly didn't do anything
with it not even combine it with uzumaki
and then bam somehow off-screen ghetto
was defeated and we have not seen this
special great cursed spirit since also
within at least pseudo ghetto's arsenal
is another assumedly registered special
great curse spirit known as the smallpox
deity and this guy has a fun
subclassification as well being a
diseased cursed spirit which spawned
from the collective negative feelings
that humanity has towards disease which
is quite understandable really
personally i'm not a big fan of disease
myself but smallpox deity is also
notable for possessing its own domain
expansion it's not the first special
grade to do so because tsukuna obviously
has his own phenomenal domain expansion
nor will smallpox deity be the last
domain wielding special grade it's just
knownable because it's a cursed spirit
that operates almost on a basic ai
system i suppose just like disease it
doesn't really think or act for itself
it just does and in the case of smallpox
deity it gets released and target
whoever has the most cursed energy
within its general vicinity so it does
not discriminate except in the way in
which it discriminates so that's 4 out
of 16 registered special grades but we
do know of potentially more and this
next one is a bit tricky because we've
not actually seen any of them but there
is a concept within the jujutsu kaisen
world known as the big three vengeful
spirits and like most of our specific
information this comes from the prequel
series where the ancestor of both yuta
okotsu and satorugojo michizanes
sugawana was said to be one of japan's
big three vengeful spirits they are
apparently exceptionally well known as
the reaction of maki panda and inumaki
upon hearing this was to label yuta as a
quote big shot sorcerer so it's another
one of those cases where it's fairly
safe to assume that these three spirits
are also registered special grades if
they still exist i guess but if they
were ranked at anything less and they
would be unlikely to be such a big deal
for whatever reasons that they are now
with that said other than michizane
sugawara the other three by which i
meant to say two the other two of the
big three eventual spirits have not been
named at least not in jude's kaisen so
it is possible that we've already met
them by which i mean rio min sukuna for
example he's known as the king of curses
but he is also classified as a vengeful
spirit so he could very well be one of
the other two although because michizana
suguara is intrinsically connected to
the gojo clan it's also quite reasonable
to propose that the other two of the big
three have links to the other two
primary jude's clans being the kamo and
zenin families so i suppose we could
identify noritoshikamo as as a maybe
potential candidate also known as
kenjaku a branco not ghetto sudo ghetto
the ghetto who is not the actual ghetto
the guy the guy we don't like with him
it's more of a semantic argument though
because due to the nature of his
existence it seems more likely that he's
still technically a sorcerer rather than
a cursed spirit and perhaps someone who
serves as more of a sorcerer parallel to
sukuna the most evil sorcerer and the
most evil cursed spirit with all of that
said there is a much more obvious answer
though because the concept of three
vengeful spirits does exist within the
real world of japanese mythology which
is a fake world but a fake while
different from jujutsu kaisen's fake
world in any case michizani sugawara has
been identified as one of them the other
two are mascarotara and emperor sutoku
all of which have very compelling
stories that we may examine at another
time however the overall point of this
video is to identify them as potential
special grade cursed spirits but that
all very much depends on how akitami
wants to proceed with what they set up
in the prequel series so that does it
for potential registered special great
curse spirits and at most we seem to
know of 7 out of the 16. however that
leads us into the wonderful world of
unregistered special grade spirits
because within jutsukai said new curses
and cursed dude creatures being born
every day and some of them happen to be
very very special our obvious first
candidate being mahito come to think
that he's probably by far the youngest
special great curse spirit in the series
even more so than rika which is
displayed quite prominently in majito's
gleeful childlike nature and a lust for
macabre knowledge about the world this
can also be seen in his relative
inexperience because while his power did
snowball quite radically he would appear
to be one of the weakest special great
curse spirits that we know of in terms
of his birth according to mahito himself
he seems to be an embodiment of hatred
that humanity possesses specifically for
one another which is likely why he takes
such pleasure from being immensely cruel
to humans and has the powerful desire to
eradicate them from the world and he
certainly isn't the only one either
because we also have three unregistered
special grades with jogo hanami and
dagon the three of them are quite
fascinating because whilst they
represent the best interests of the
environment they were of course born
from human emotion just like everything
else specifically these guys are the
manifestation of human fear of natural
disasters which does go on to inform why
they wish to read the world of humanity
because that's what humans see natural
disasters is doing they're particularly
special and wildly powerful though and
in fact all three of them seem to
possess not only a domain expansion but
a mastery of said expansion although
sadly we never got to see honey's domain
not every special grade is a big world
ending threat though and this is where
we start to get a bit more technical
because the finger bearers would also be
classified as special great cursed
spirits this brand of creature is born
from a coast womb coming into contact
with one of sukunis fingies which they
themselves are known as special great
cursed objects but the wombs then intake
a portion of sukunis power which then
turns them into a special grade curve
spirit all on their own although it must
be mentioned that this is where the
classification system gets kind of
muddled because as sukuna himself notes
they are nowhere near on par with any of
the special grades we've examined so far
it's more that the ranking system is
rather flawed because the grades lower
than special have become all but
meaningless because almost every threat
we encounter is special grade and
there's a wide variety of those and that
does of course also include our good
friends the death paintings with choso
eso and keichizu we have another batch
of three unregistered special grades and
potentially even six others that we have
yet to see because naritoshikama was a
very naughty boy and did allegedly craft
nine of these existences that we know
and once again these special grades
don't scale particularly well against
many of the others we've examined i mean
to compare the death paintings to
existences such as such an eureka or
even mojito they result in quite a
lacking feeling really i mean special
grade spirits almost need an entirely
new subclassification system within
itself i think because right now as i
said the term is well it's more or less
meaningless because you can be a special
great cursed spirit and be capable of
being defeated by first year jujutsu
students or you can be a special great
cursed spirit and possess the powers of
what is essentially an almost literal
god there's no real distinction between
the two but also this is an interesting
narrative hole that al katami kind of
dug for themselves because we were
fighting special great co-spirits pretty
much right from the get-go the very
second arc of the series featured our
students fighting a finger bearer so we
started our journey at the very top of
the curse spirit hierarchy which is
problematic because for a story to be a
story we need to continue escalating
from there and in terms of
classifications there was just there was
nowhere else to go that's not quite it
though because there are a couple of
cases of maybe special great cursed
spirits which we aren't quite sure of a
good example of which would be the
kuchisaka honor yet another imaginary
vengeful curse spirit at the disposal of
sugar ghetto which seems pretty damn
powerful because while she doesn't have
a literal domain expansion the gujisake
honor is actually capable of trapping
people within her innate domain and i
feel like that concept needs a word if
our general use of domains is called a
domain expansion then maybe this could
be a domain inversion or something i
don't know with that said this spirit's
grade was never designated given its
sheer power you'd have to assume that
it's at least a semi-grade one but
probably more because the other
semi-grade one's been they've been
pretty meh in comparison to the
kuchisaka honor so maybe it's a special
grade then maybe it's not i don't know
but in essence when it comes to jiu
jitsu kaisen it's usually safe to assume
that if a cursed spirit is acting as any
kind of major or maybe even minor plot
line in most stories it's almost
certainly going to be a special grade
and while the hierarchy of jujuta
sorcerer grades are fairly meticulously
laid out and defined we get a bit more
meh when it comes to cursed spirits in
fact to this day we haven't even
encountered any grade one or special
grade one cursed spirits if they do
exist at all we just seem to go straight
from a handful of semi-grade ones and
then immediately into the special grade
which is where about 90 of our relevant
spirits lay but to find out some even
more relevant content here is another
video a video for you because there's
always more to learn explore and
experience with this wonderful series so
i look forward to seeing you there